hi Melissa Clark pleasure me so what do
you have here in this very nice looking
very symmetrical dish this is from 1942
cookbook from Columbia University it's a
family lamb dinner ok so what it was is
lamb shanks we took it off the bone we
braise them to put up then we follow the
recipe to keynote with this is they
finished the lamb with a cream sauce
when I first opened the Colombian 1942
cookbook it was like finding a little
time capsule it was so wonderful because
all of these recipes are not the kind of
recipes that you see even in retro
cookbooks or cook books that are
historical these are the real things
that people were cooking and what struck
me was how first of all how voic-- they
were each recipe was just so wonderfully
it just sounded like the person was
talking to me and telling me how they
made the recipe you go back to 1940s
health wasn't an issue at the time fat
content saturated fat content trans fat
gluten stuff like that so to way we cook
now it's a more healthier version we do
a lot healthier and it's different
things we do to protect the people who
eat who have the allergens back then it
was like here's what we're eating today
and if you're in this kind of household
this is what you ate and that it
definitely shows in the recipes in that
book the Columbia cookbook reminded me
of the community cookbooks that are
fairly frequently published there's one
in my small town state of local woman's
group who collected recipes and
presented those recipes of prominent
people in town so you have a not
surprising a portrait of Columbia
population it's a well-traveled
population there a fair number of
foreign preparation sometimes will tell
you in parentheses Egyptian in case you
didn't know and someone
with an Italian name probably from Italy
giving the real scoop on against all the
crimes done in the name of spaghetti
something delightful that I found in the
book was it was this just um
unapologetic use of awful I thought it
was great there was kidneys their work
is erds there were there was tongue
there were all kinds of things that
today if I wrote a recipe calling for
kidneys I would have to do a big long
apology like really these are delicious
I promise but back then it was just take
it for granted so in one way you know
we've come a long way we're eating a
fresher we're eating fewer canned and
boxed products but then again we're also
more limited in what we eat we don't
have we're not eating all of the animal
the way they were back then and I think
that is a great lesson for us we don't
get to cook that way anymore I can it
protein or meat or beefs items to a
vegetarian dish we made a planted today
a call so back fat we use bacon there's
no way in multi feelings you could put
bacon and some like that because so many
people don't like pork or don't eat
bacon or can't eat meat because a
vegetarian or vegan we learned how to
adapt to make people happy so we're
trying to make the mess is happy instead
of individual families with these
recipes were made for these both have
apple these are is like similar apple
pies yes sailing same crust and this has
a top crust and this has Jesus that just
sounds so I don't want to eat rat cheese
but I in 1942 maybe in America youíre
wretches any cheese that was born or
raised or grew in America are made in
America what's it it just good for rat
traps that's what he got the same rat
cheese oh I have a feeling though if
they're putting it on pie that means and
especially Eisenhower is putting on a
pie i'm assuming that means that there
is a it said with affection and love it
is rat cheese but yet it is beloved
because here it is on this pie and you
know it is very i mean we do have the
tradition in America especially in you
know up in the northeast of serving
cheddar cheese with pie that's very
traditional so this is kind of a take on
that tastes change over the years and
the way that we like our food done today
is different from back in the 40s for
example the cooking times on some of the
recipes we would never cook fish for an
hour and a half we just wouldn't it
would fall apart but you know what
that's how they liked it back then and
that's
ballad and it is a it's just a
difference in taste and our taste is our
own but it doesn't necessarily mean it's
any better